up this went viral on Twitter last night
it's important essay whatever your
belief Robert Kagan you claimed a story
and of course associated with Brookings
in the washington post on fascism we
talked to ian bremmer about this two
days ago delicately these are just two
thoughts successful fascism was not
about policies but about the strongmen
the leader and whom could be entrusted
the fate of a nation whatever the
problem that leader could fix it and
then dr. Kagen moves on to what these
people do not or will not see this being
Republican supporters of mr. Trump is it
once in power mr. Trump will owe them
and their party nothing this is your
first read into the weekend you may
agree with it you may disagree with it
but there's a polarity as we go into our
political summer Ian Shepherdson with us
with Pantheon macroeconomics kit Juckes
with us in London as well Ian the
backdrop for this is an economy it's the
economy in election I'm sorry it's not
is it what it is and it isn't because
it's the economy that has driven the
rise of Trump because he appeared
Sanders let's do yeah and sounds both of
them both of them are addressing the
issue that the main streams of the
parties haven't addressed which is the
hollowing out of an awful lot of mostly
blue-collar jobs across the country over
the last 20 30 years the flattening of
living standards over an extended period
which the traditional parties and the
main streams have had very little to say
about and Sanders and Trump have picked
up on the right that the problems that
this is cause for a large number of
people and have pushed it in kind of
alarming area and then within the going
into this weekend the Stanley Fisher
paper with Columbia University in
Woodford the assumption of your
academics is it's all in together
America it's a one mode America the fact
is it's not John Edwards is right it's a
minimum to America and it's a bimodal
analysis do you use that within your
economic study well this is where
economists kind of go wrong because we
tend to look at that overall picture and
we say that okay a trade deal NAFTA or
whatever has generated a net gain
overall what we tend not to have much to
say about is the distribution and there
are there are winners and losers the
losers have lost a lot and there's a lot
of them I mean the traditional parties
haven't spoken to those those
and I want to point out here Francine
Phil verla ger who was with us on oil
the other day was courageous in his
comments like Ian Shepherdson on NAFTA
and the effect of that upon to America's
is mr. Trump and Mr Sanders speak of
yeah and Tom I guess the problem when
you said on this side of the Atlantic is
that you're also waiting for guidance
away from the party politics away from
the hysteria to just simply understand
from an economic point of view what if
Donald Trump presidency would look like
what does it mean for trade was it mean
for fiscal deficit what does it mean
even for bondholders given the recent
comments in what would it look like is
it too soon to know because he changes
facets everything yeah it's another day
and another proposal I think that the
thing to bear in mind about Trump is it
if he's elected he goes to the hill with
very few allies and that makes it kind
of difficult for him to get anything
done he would be there in charge of one
branch of the government but not in
control of Congress and we've seen over
the last couple of years of the Obama
administration if you don't have a lot
of friends on the hill it's very hard to
get anything done so while he says some
very very alarming things at a headline
level his ability to actually do any of
it I think it's going to be very
constrained so he would be in office but
not really in power from an economic
perspective thankfully right but yeah I
guess if you were elected he would
distill the sense of a lot of the world
superpowers becoming more inward-looking
what does that do to world growth in the
next five to ten years well you know if
everyone turns inwards and what you end
up with is a declining spiral in World
Trade which we saw in the 1930s and it
didn't end very well it would be you
know one of the growth of world trade
volumes has lifted hundreds of millions
of people out of poverty over the last
two or three decades and the last thing
that we want from a global perspective
if you like is an unwinding of those
gains but what Trump has been pointing
out is that those games globally have
imposed substantial losses on lots of
people in the US and other developed
economies as well and what he's speaking
to is the people who have been
dispossessed by trade the problem is
that you know the net from it from a
global perspective trade makes everybody
better off what economists and
politicians haven't found is the answer
to how to deal with the people who lose
out and just denying that people have
lost out which has been the mainstream
response just doesn't cut it anymore
because
clearly they have lost out kids if I can
bring you in here this is all applicable
and the brakes of debate as well right
this is partially why the exit campaign
and nationalism is on the rise in
Britain in a different way than it used
to be well this is a debate everywhere I
mean I agree with everything in said
although I would say you know if we if
we see a downward spiral in World Trade
as we become more insular what will move
will be the people from the poor
countries that were surviving by
exporting who were going to come and
they'll come whether we put walls
whether we leave the EU whether we
whatever we do those people now will get
in boats or they'll get in cars I'll get
into and so this this issue of the
inequality isn't going away nor is the
issue of the economic and political
mainstream's inability to listen to
these voices so we're going to hear this
all over Europe will hear a front seam
will hear it in Italy will hear it in
France will hear it in Germany will hear
at my pain and and we're going to shout
about it for the next six weeks